this is one of my favorite
demonstrations I have here two balloons
joined by a closed valve one of the
balloons contains more air than the
other this is just any little guy but
not for long when I open the valve the
balloons will become connected and
they'll equalize and this guy will get
bigger ready three two one
[Music]
this phenomenon can seem
counterintuitive it's almost as if big
balloons suck but it's less surprising
when you remember that blowing up a
balloon is difficult at first
and then it gets easier
that's because as you fill a balloon
with air its rubber gets stretched
thinner and thinner but the thicker the
rubber is the more pressure it can exert
on the air inside so the less inflated a
balloon is the higher the pressure
inside will be so small balloons might
be cute but they are Mighty uh you can't
bully me around big guy take it take it
foreign
[Music]